[Music]
so we we've done about 20 minutes and we
haven't really really mentioned morality
or what or what the purpose of your
original video was in your category now
I watch them both again this morning
because I really wanted to have them
fresh in my mind and I and I kind of
struggled with how exactly I was going
to frame this because I thought well
maybe if I just go off your video that
would be the right way because you did
the counter video then I thought maybe I
need to bounce back and forth between a
few things so I'm going to bounce around
I have a feeling that I've got two
people of intellect that can follow me
here so so one of the things that you
talked about so let's shift this into
morality God and and murder so you talk
about scientific facts verse moral facts
and I think people can probably figure
out what that means but but can you just
explain that concept again well the I
think everyone can understand and I and
I'm not saying this in a condescending
way that if you don't agree with me
you're here you're not on my level of
understanding but I think it's axiomatic
that you can't learn morality from
nature nature especially if you believe
in the survival of the fittest if that's
your guideline and that was a guideline
for people like Hitler that he actually
did say that but even dropping any
reference to a given mass murderer their
science doesn't tell me to be honorable
science doesn't tell me to to do
anything against my self-interest The
Selfish Gene written by an atheist that
we are we're composed of selfish genes
you need you need a mind and you need I
believe an outside source to say this is
what is right this is what is wrong
because science doesn't tell you that
that's all it's not it's not a that's
not I don't even think that's debatable
how do I know enough not to steal
because of atoms or or or biology I
don't think you do well your moral
conscience tells you that and where did
that come from
okay so let's pull back for a second so
your
open up his murder wrong okay what is
murders let's define some terms here to
get us some clarification murder is the
wrongful killing of one human by another
so it's like asking is wrong wrong yes
it's right there in the word so maybe we
mean is killing wrong no no we meant is
murder I meant this murder all by
definition is it's right yes
why you definitely yes by definition but
but that's not the issue my video is not
is is why is murder wrong not whether it
is wrong yeah why is it wrong why is it
wrong because we've defined it that way
okay but that's my argument yes but my
argument is that's the whole point if
we've defined it that way then we are
god and we could say murder murder
blacks murder Jews murder gays right no
no because of okay so two things one
first of all if you say that well it's
God that told told us that it's wrong
you know all right so first of all did
God have reasons for why murder is wrong
or is he just randomly declaring this
and that wrong or right
my guess is you'd say he had reasons and
so the question is what are those
reasons and why not skip the divine
middleman and just base our moral
reasoning on those reasons that we too
can come up with moral reasoning because
well I wish it worked because my bottom
line is I just want people to do good
yes
if a theist I'm much closer to what a
good atheist and a bad religious person
so my bottom line is goodness but I that
a very young age that reason doesn't
take me to goodness reason is a tool
reason is a hammer
hammers build hospitals and hammers
build torture chambers yeah so a reason
does reason is great but it doesn't give
you the goal reason gives you the means
but but the public how do you know that
Martin murder is wrong from from the
divine command there in your perspective
I mean you said you don't talk to gut
you know you're not my Bible I believe
in Revelation I do believe the Ten
Commandments were revealed
okay so again so you know as you know
Plato refuted this argument 2500 years
ago if God is just declaring things
random
then then if he if he didn't say murder
was wrong would that make it okay well
to was to be to be a consistent it would
be but he didn't do that so it's
irrelevant it's like if there's an old
leader saying if my you know my
grandmother had balls she'd be my
grandfather yeah okay so this is not an
if if that that matters it turns out
that moral reasoning and what God is
dictating seem to coincide very often
but that's not the issue remember my
issue is beyond what we're speaking
about there is no forgetting murder for
a moment there is no good and evil if
there is no God there were only opinions
about good and evil just like Beauty do
you think there's an objective beauty I
think there's a basis to it yes what
does that mean that evolved propensity
to prefer some characteristics in people
and land all right but it doesn't make
something beautiful about less thank you
okay but but what do you mean by
objective objective that it has just
this objectively this cup this this
glass exists so it's not just it's not a
reminder to my opinion that's a record
so I think I think moral values actually
have a factual basis that are like the
glass a little more complicated but
based on our human nature - so you
mentioned The Selfish Gene we do have
our inner demons that cause us to want
to be selfish and greedy and avarice and
so forth but we also have our better
angels that is it pays to be cooperative
nice altruistic and caring and loving
for other human beings particularly
those in your tribe and and it benefits
yourself as genes to be nice to other
people now immediately in your in your
immediate family extended family and
your community and studies show this
does pay off now unfortunately we're
very tribal to other people who may be
threatening our empathetic notions about
our fellow beings but that's involved
characteristic we can see it in primates
and children and so on there's a deep
sense from the moment you're born of
there's a right and a wrong and and that
comes from this evolved propensity to
survive in a social
unity you can't survive by murdering
cheating line and so forth and so that's
where it comes from and I consider that
to be transcendent of you and me it's
not my opinions not your opinion it
belongs to the species we're born that
way lions don't have that chips don't
quite have that like we have it and so
on does this there's a you know a scale
of this so one of my favorite videos
from frogs of all is that the two little
capuchin monkeys that are each taught to
swap a pebble for a grape or a cucumber
slice so it's the pebbles are like money
so they so you see this video where the
experimenter gives the one a pebble he
gives it back and he gets a cucumber
slice the eats it he's happy then the
other one does the same thing and he
gets a grape now they like grapes better
than cucumbers because who doesn't and
and so the other one the first one sees
that he goes oh boy I'm going to get a
grape and he runs and gets his pebble
and he puts the Tuffle an experimenter
gives a few cumber slice in each foot
and you see him he throws it at the
experimenter he's pounding on the cages
rattling the cage wall he is pissed
because that guy got something I didn't
get that was not right I did the same
amount of work that he did and he got
something so you can see that sent they
don't have language they can't call it
anything but they have a sense of wrong
I was wrong that was okay so let me
respond yeah that experiment does not
show what you just said that experiment
shows that he's pissed on his behalf you
find me one monkey on the face of the
earth that rattles the cage because the
other guy was wronged then I will take
that argument series and actually this
is completely selfish base number two
you mentioned children so you have
raised I know that not yes it is selfish
base but it's about what's right and
wrong with Barry for me no no no so it's
not about right and wrong it's about me
I feel gypped that doesn't count but it
that's bigger rattle cages on behalf of
other 'mo now it's a sense of fairness
like I want what's right for me yes for
me and then what I know well what's
right for you fair but what does it take
for us to scale up to for me to care
about what's right for me
to care about what's right for you it
takes transcendent morality it doesn't
take so much if you take children you
mentioned children here's the idea that
we could learn that children are born
with
a strong moral sense I mean you read
Lord of the Flies I think that's far
more accurate let me just ask you what
you raised a child right and so I just
want to ask you how many times do you
feel roughly you told her say thank you
10,000 done I've not that many times I
know that you just have to know a little
bit nudge them a little bit I'll please
the real white high child of Ella I told
I told my son's at each of them at least
ten thousand times they like say thank
you if they were inherently good they
would person will never have to be told
the first is not certainly not many
other times not black and white it's all
they're all good or they're all evil no
no no no but don't say we can learn that
we have this great we built-in sense
dude we are white in the world state a
repo world is a filled wife slavery
universal rape universal murder
universal well we know even this is
rarer than than all of the Arab lies but
but it's been changing and there's a
reason for that and the reason is reason
ever since the Enlightenment we've been
changing the conditions of society
politics economics and social systems to
emphasize the better angels and squish
you know sorta ten you ate the the inner
demons and we know how to do this it's
sort of like a behavioral game matrix
like okay we're going to encroach so we
have this debate two hundred years ago
right before the right before the
Enlightenment you would have agreed with
me I probably would have been religious
and we probably would have been on the
same well on pro-slavery and so forth
well I do think this is an interesting
point because when I had you on just a
couple months ago and you were arguing
for morality through a judeo-christian
value a lot of people were saying to me
he's actually just arguing for
enlightenment values which I thought
what I think so I think that's the kill
no no I think you're but I've been
influenced by the alignment very much
III can answer you I having been raised
in my specification which is probably
truly irrelevant to the point but in my
specific case I assure you I was raised
in an Orthodox Jewish Melia Oh half the
day Hebrew studies in Hebrew
of the Bible and the Talmud and so on
and half today secular studies I if I
would have said to one of my rabbis from
Eastern Europe the French enlightenment
he would have he would have looked
around and you know was that the name of
it of Anu I don't know well not not rock
group he didn't know a lot but anyway he
would have thought maybe it was a food
French enlightenment right but that
might have showed the limitations of his
thinking though yes I agree with you but
that's not the point the point is what
influenced me more I don't I don't know
I I believe that God wanting to me good
God demands that I be good is the single
most animating thing in my life and I
want it to be the most animating thing
in everybody's life I don't trust people
who listen to their inner voice a
handful of occasions it will work for
the vast majority of people the inner
voice will be if a young man can get
away with grabbing a woman the inner
voice will be dwarfed by his
testosterone so all right so that it's a
good segue to two things so first I just
want to jump back to the monkey yes
ample in a second because do you think
it's possible that if they kept doing
that experiment over time the monkey who
was seeing his friend be wronged would
eventually start because there is on
behalf of the monkey because that
doesn't I think that would strengthen
that argument I don't know that they
okay so it's a process involves research
shows that you can nudge it in that
direction not very far so he does
research with elephants and you know
other mammals and you can get them just
it you can see that they start to care
for the other individual if they're
being harmed like like they're getting
electric shocks if they do something
that sacrifices themselves to stop the
electric shock right when you say labret
than a cucumber the day a monkey starts
rattling the cage because his friend got
a cucumber right but I will be impressed
yes okay okay then also read Paul
Bloom's book just babies so they show
that like these little things at the
infant they can't speak yet okay so but
they're doing these little puppet things
and they have a puppet show where the
one puppet is trying to push this ball
up a ramp and another puppet comes in
and pushes them back down and they say
eles or the other one the other puppet
comes up and helps him right so then
they show the babies they get to pick
which puppet they like the most and they
always like the one that helped right
and and and so blooms got these great
videos where you can see a lot of times
these little babies will reach out and
slap that the bad puppet you know it's
like that that Bette puppet puppet was
bad so this is said like six months a
year old year and a half they already
have a sense of that's right and that's
wrong helping is good harming is not
good okay now so we don't need to go
from there to say well that how you
explain evil it's in there we have inner
demons we also have that I think why I
think that's true I think that they're a
good job you might say well God God put
it in there but to get back to my
earlier point how do you know so you
said revelation but you you mean they
wrote the Bible the Old Testament so so
but other religious leaders like the
leader of Isis you know Baghdad he said
yeah he says I get revelation from that
I know what's right right well I have an
answer to that I have an answer like you
I'm curious to hear your answer because
I've heard this a lot of it's a it's a
plausible argument how do you know which
God for them okay if if I came along and
I and I developed a brown bubbly drink
and said this is Coca Cola and you would
say well there really is a real Coca
Cola you are making up something new
well beyond act chronologically the
original coca-cola it's your recipe it
doesn't taste like it it doesn't look
like it and you don't have the same
ingredients but you're calling it
coca-cola God was introduced to humanity
by the old testament that everybody
acknowledges alright that's the God I'm
talking about if there are variations on
that theme that's their business there
is a Coca Cola and I'm talking about
Coca Cola I'm talking about the God
given to humanity through the Old
Testament that God gave the Ten
Commandments in my view and that made
murder absolutely wrong not dependent
upon personal or societal opinion so
what what about right before that life
for that happen there were 80 people for
2 birthdays before there were a lot of
people who thought murder was wrong I
have the course that's true but it
wasn't objectively wrong it was
subjectively wrong and there's a big
difference I am now telling you God says
that the that killing wrongly is
absolutely wrong there is an objective
morality here which it commandant are
you talking about it for 6 so this is
thou shalt not kill no murder
if the Hebrew and the English are murder
case again back to my original point by
definition it's wrong I know what I'm
talking about knowing but but wrongful
killing right wrongful killer son
killing is OK [ __ ] says yes of course
that's true some sex is ok some sex is
rape right that's true about every
action
[Music]
you